hey guys how's it going so I am so
excited because today's cooking video is
going to be a little bit different this
is actually sort of a challenge video
for not only you guys but for myself I
partnered up with Walmart and I'm
hosting their gametime MVP contest so
I'm the host there's also three other
captains
now these captains are going to be
giving you guys challenges that you have
to complete this first challenge is
called a new take on nachos which is why
I don't actually have any chips in front
of me you might see I've got you dated
spot these are gonna be called Pacho the
captain for this challenge is cook with
April so be sure to go check out her
channel and watch her video because she
actually knows how to cook so April
please come over please help me will
just mean why would I want to do these
challenges because you can win a chance
to come out here to Los Angeles to meet
me to meet the other three captains and
you'll be going to an eat & Greet at the
YouTube space alright let's get started
because I am having a party later I'm
pretty excited that is now football
season so we'll be watching the games I
need a plate if only were up night why
would I normal player ok mmm
it's going well already mmm plate so to
hook with tots you're just gonna you're
gonna get a pan and you're gonna dump
them onto the pan like so ok
now watch me cook holy moly that's hot
and a medium bowl mix together the sour
cream the seasoning mix where's my
seasoning mix it says what's was nice
this is some ranch seasoning I like
ranch so we'll put a little extra in I
think that's 2 tablespoons what you
think a little puppy right here he's
hungry I think he's run like when you
shut up and trying to sleep I got a
ranch mix and then next we're going to
put in it says we're gonna put in chives
I didn't know chives looked like grass
hmm Wow look at this this is actually
pretty easy cool well I'm really glad
you should challenge yourself daily
speaking of challenge if you guys want
to enter this challenge all you have to
do is go and recreate some sort of
nachos yourself take a picture and post
it on Instagram and use the hashtag
Walmart MVP contest that's it and what's
great is the winner of each of those
challenges will be flown out here to Los
Angeles to hang out with us which is
gonna be so much fun I can't wait I love
meeting you guys it's so crazy like you
watch the videos you know me I don't
know you so getting to meet you guys in
real life is really fun so now I'm just
gonna mix it up how are these doing hmm
looking good I am so excited to be
working on this project with Walmart
because if you guys have ever watched
any of my vlogs you know one of my most
fun things to do is go to the store and
get some goodies since I started making
cooking videos I never actually realized
how much fun I would have making food I
definitely have more fun eating it but
the process of making it quite enjoyable
because I get to sample mmm bacon
nice taste alright I'm gonna take these
tots out I'm just gonna scoot them on my
friends are gonna be so impressed with
my cooking skills they're gonna be like
wow just seeing you really went all out
for this game they're not even gonna
believe that I made this myself until
they watched the video okay so ranch mix
will put on top we might as well just
put it all on because this looks amazing
lather that up real nice okay well this
looks really amazing and some bacon bits
now you can always leave this out
because if your friends want to add some
more they can do as they please but I
like bacon so we're gonna put on a lot
of bacon it's gonna pile that on hope
you're not a vegetarian
just press that in real nice
excuse you this is amazing
these are my tacos they're not nachos
but there are nachos you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you like it and be
sure to subscribe to see more cooking
videos and more fun random things here
on my channel and most importantly few
guys might enter this contest like I
said take an Instagram photo of your
take on nachos
check out cook with April's channel and
use the hashtag Walmart MVP contest on
that Instagram photo so you could be
entered for a chance to come out here to
Los Angeles and hang out with us and
make videos and it's gonna be really
cool I'm so excited to see all of your
entries on your take of nachos you don't
have to make exactly what I made but
this is quite fantastic and if you want
to attempt this I'll put a link in the
description for this recipe along with
all the other information about the
gametime MVP contest with Walmart so
that's it I'm gonna go I'll see you guys
later and hopefully I will see one two
three a few of you guys out here see you
later bye I'm gonna take this with me
hey friends thank you so much for tuning
in to cook with April today I'm really
excited because Walmart is launching the
game time MVP contest